chaos and violence continue to rack
wisconsin protesters try to mob dc
diners into pledging fealty to black
lives matter and the trump campaign
rolls out the second night of the rnc
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
ben well the country is in chaos i mean
it's impossible to look at the images
coming out of kenosha wisconsin
and not feel that something is
fundamentally broken in our society
violence broke out again
in kenosha last night i look forward to
the statements of empathy
from vice president joe biden and kamala
harris and from governor tony evers
we heard politicians on all sides of the
democratic party
discussing the evils of america the
systemic racism of the united states
discussing
the awful terrible evil kenosha police
department without full evidence being
in
in the jacob blake shooting based on
fragmentary video taken
from a distance without any lead up
without any understanding of what
exactly happened
well now there have been more shootings
in kenosha there are businesses that are
burned down in kenosha
it turns out that when you slander all
police officers as systemically racist
when you say the country is systemically
racist
when you make excuses for rioters and
looters and people who would do violence
assault to other human beings
when you do all of those things and then
you incentivize the police
to move out well what happens to follow
is quite terrible
last night in kenosha three people were
shot i look forward to the lamentations
and empathy
from all of these same democratic
figures perhaps they will because it
turns out that some of the people who
were shot were some of the protesters
it turns out that according to various
media reports and the information is
still coming in
it is unclear who was shooting and who
was shot it appears that the
quote-unquote protesters who in this
case were rioters and looters
were shot and that some of the people
who may have done the shooting may have
been it is unclear again
at this point people who are defending
their for example car dealerships
against looters who are attempting to
loot those car dealerships
so perhaps the democrats will sound off
about that we've seen some evidence of
that
so far already if it is writers or
looters obviously doing the violence
that is a different thing
then we will just not mention it or
pretend that it doesn't exist or pretend
that it is all justified
in any case here is the new york times
report on what happened and by the way
it is worthwhile noting the real
reporting on the ground is being done
by central right outlets it's being done
by the daily caller it's being done by
townhall.com
it is not in fact being done by anybody
in the mainstream media who are just
cribbing off the work
of these right-wing outlets mainly
because it turns out that
so many of these insane mainstream
left-wing outlets have decided
that it was totally not worth even
covering all of this stuff
these were all as well as just normal
goings about a business
it was left to censor right outlets to
actually cover what's going on on the
ground
so according to the new york times three
people were shot early on wednesday two
fatally
according to law enforcement officials
during a chaotic night of demonstrations
over the shooting of jacob blake
a black resident whose children were
nearby as their father was shot this
week by a white police officer
now they're not going to tell you the
full story of jacob lake there are new
details that are emerging in the
shooting of it jacob blake we'll discuss
that in a moment because
as it turns out we now have a spate of
high-profile police-involved shootings
in which you have not been told the full
story
or police killings in which you have not
been told the full story and then when
new details emerge it actually
does extraordinary extraordinary
chaos to the original narrative that was
trotted out by the media we'll get to
those in a second
according to the new york times in
kenosha a third night of protests over
the shooting of mr blake i like third
end of protest it's not protest when
you're burning crap and trying to wreck
cars and
setting things on fire that's not a
protest it's a riot and the media don't
get to play this game
where when president trump condemns
rioters and looters or when people on
the right condemn writers and looters
they say ah
you're just trying to shut down first
amendment approved protest and then as
soon as you say no no the protesters are
different than the writers and looters
they say
no they're all part of the same group
okay well you can't have it both ways
either they are or they ain't
by people who are running around in the
streets trying to break stuff and do
violence to people are not in fact
protesters they're in fact rioters and
looters and people who are violating
criminal law
in kenosha a third night of protests
over the shooting of mr blake stretched
into the early morning hours of
wednesday
after demonstrators clashed with law
enforcement officials near the county
courthouse
downtown tuesday evening was spent in a
shifting hours-long standoff between
police and protesters
protesters assembled outside a newly
erected metal barrier protecting the
courthouse and threw
water bottles rocks and fireworks at the
police
and we can actually see all of this
stuff happening here's some rioters
trying to tear down the fence
outside the kenosha county courthouse
and chucking fireworks
at the police this would be
clip five so you can see these rioters
trying to do violence here they are
trying to
i mean this looks like portland right
here they are and it is not
just people of color you're seeing a lot
of white faces in this crowd a lot of
white faces pushing the black lives
matter
movement here a lot of dispossessed
white people
woke white jackasses shining lasers into
the
eyes of police officers throwing objects
at police officers these are not
demonstrators these are now rioters
once you attack police officers you are
now a rioter people were
burning flags outside the fence burning
american flags always a good look
by the way for the republican national
convention honestly they should just
livestream this
they really should because this is what
democrats allow to happen in their
states
because as it turns out governor tony
evers the jackass
governor of wisconsin he was offered
more national guard by the federal
government he turned it down we'll get
to that in a moment as well
now this is a continuation of a trend
that has been happening overnight we're
going to get back to these shootings
that happen in kenosha in just a second
there's been a trend that's been
happening over the course of the last
48 hours and it's resulted in some
pretty astonishing tape
some really astonishing tape we'll get
to that in just a moment
first let us talk about how you can save
money this year okay you know even in
down times even when it appears the
country's falling apart it's still
important you don't spend too much money
on things that you don't need to spend
money on
one of those things your cell phone bill
you're probably spending too much money
on your cell phone bill
maybe up to twice as much as you ought
to be spending because you've got that
unlimited data that you're not actually
using well if you're using att or
verizon or t-mobile what if i told you
that puretalk usa uses the exact same
network as one of those carriers same
towers
same exact coverage but literally will
cost you half how do they make it so
affordable well there are no retail
stores so low overhead you're not
funding their billion dollar ad
campaigns you're only paying for the
data you need
no contract no excessive fees you'll
enjoy unlimited talk text and two gigs
of data all for just 20 bucks a month
that's correct the average person is
saving 400 a year on their wireless bill
so go grab your mobile phone dial pound
250 and say ben
shapiro when you do you get this amazing
deal and save 50
off your first month again that is pound
two five zero say keyword ben
shapiro to get involved with pure talk
usa save a bunch of money on your cell
phone bill
go right now dial pound 250 say keyword
ben shapiro
and you get that amazing deal you're
saving up to 400 bucks a year on your
wireless bill and you save 50
off your first month just by dialing
pound 250 and saying ben shapiro and
joining
pure talk usa okay so the tape over the
last 48 hours from kenosha wisconsin
is absolutely astonishing and there is a
looters were assaulting
a business and a business owner charged
out and started spraying them with a
fire extinguisher which is not a deadly
weapon
it's a fire extinguisher it is deadly to
fire and
naturally this led one of the looters to
run over uh looks like a young black man
runs over and he clocks this elderly
business owner a guy's probably 60
maybe clocks him directly in the face
knocks him directly out this is what's
gonna happen to every one of you
when this pizza goes nationwide i don't
think you realize this
please guys we are trying to protect
ourselves hey you got alcohol you don't
understand
what terrifies
it's that last lady i want to focus on
her commentary there you don't
understand you don't understand
these black men out here they're
terrified for their lives oh really so
that necessitates them looting stores
and beating the living hell out of
business owners
it seems like everything is okay so long
as the color of your skin is approved by
the woke media
very very it's an interesting take it's
an interesting take
that basically you're in fear for your
life so you go and you break into a
store and you steal crap when the
business owner shows up and sprays you
the fire extinguisher you literally beat
him
that makes perfect sense you're so
fearful of the police officers that you
do something
illegal and then you beat a civilian
makes perfect sense to me
obviously systemic racism and again as i
mentioned yesterday
this unbelievable anti-logical shift has
happened
on the left it used to be that the left
was interested in fighting racism
because they wanted people to have the
ability to make free decisions
and bear the consequences of those
decisions that was the purpose of
getting rid of racism
now if you make a free and bad decision
we just blame racism so racism becomes a
tool
rather than an obstacle using using
racism as a tool
becomes a purposeful attempt to excuse
awful and evil behavior like being
living hell out of business owners and
looting their businesses
another tape came out from kenosha
yesterday a blm supporter
telling members of the media that you
know what when this sort of stuff
happens
all right because i feel they're paying
i condone this sort of activity
absolutely
i don't support violence but people will
see
people will come out and people will
talk when they
feel it you know what i'm saying it's a
feeling that's the only way you can make
other people feel
and when they are being hurt when their
pockets are being hurt
then they will say something
so so by burning down buildings that
that gives a voice
to black lives matter is what you're i i
don't really i condone them berlin
building down i condone them building
and burning the buildings down yeah
because you know what it's all part of
the systemic racism narrative the way
that you
end systemic racism is by blaming all
individual bad behavior on systemic
racism so the worse the behavior the
worse the systemic racism
by by backwards logic and now the real
cost to this
i know that the democrats have been
pulling this and pretending it doesn't
exist or making excuses for it
in the ugliest possible fashion but this
has real consequences
so giulio rosas over at townhall.com has
been doing some excellent on the ground
reporting
over in kenosha he interviewed a couple
of business owners named scott carpenter
and his mom linda they owned a furniture
store it was completely burned to the
ground
absolutely burned to the ground okay but
but apparently these costs don't matter
i'm not hearing a lot of empathy
remember last week was all empathy week
at the democratic national convention
nutting a lot of empathy for business
owners who for no reason at all
have their businesses completely burned
to the ground by rioters and looters
sporting the black lives matter slogan
here are these business owners who just
watched their life savings disappear in
smoke
we pay for insurance that causes
insurance rates to go up
it's basically that they just stole from
us whoever did this stole from us
and that raises the cost of everything
cost of living goes up because of that
cost of insurance goes up when when
insurance claims have to be made i don't
think it's justified for anyone to ruin
anybody else's property it's against the
law they're already put in prison
and order have to be paid made to pay
back what they've destroyed
nah nah what nah well of course not
that's silly that's silly well the
predictable result of all this is the
business owners
whose businesses are being left to the
to to the handling
the tender mercies of rioters and
looters who are being
basically allowed to roam free by the
governor of the state tony evers as i
mentioned before
tony evers rejected more national guard
help
he was offered it he put out a little
statement which was very important
his statement was tonight and in the
dark and in the days ahead
if you are going to protest please do so
peacefully and safely please do not
allow the actions of a few
to distract us from the work we must do
together to demand justice equity and
accountability so big statement there
from governor tony evers
president trump last night tweeted out
the governor should call in the national
guard in wisconsin it's ready willing
and more than able end the problem fast
it was now reported that local law
enforcement wisconsin told the white
house they needed at least 750
national guard last night governor evers
sends 250.
today mark meadows the chief of staff at
the white house called the governor and
offered 500 additional guards to meet
the police needs
and governor evers declined but he did
release a statement
ooh a statement yesterday governor evers
what a wonderful governor he is
the governor of wisconsin here was his
statement you ready
listen to the harshness of the language
he uses with regard to america versus
the the
tender mercies that he uses with regard
to people who are violently looting and
burning things
quote the ability to exercise first
amendment rights is a critically
important part of our democracy and the
pursuit of justice
but there remains a line between
peaceful assembly and what we saw last
night that put individuals families and
businesses in danger
we cannot forget the reason why these
protests began and what we've seen play
out over the last two nights and many
nights this year is the pain
anguish and exhaustion of being black in
our state in our country
also the natural consequence of being
black in the united states and black in
wisconsin
is apparently putting individuals
families and businesses in danger i mean
that's his language which is
absolutely insane it is derogatory
toward black americans it assumes they
have no agency it assumes they cannot
obey the law or should not obey the law
given
the status of black americans in our
society which is patently loony
here's tony evers garbage governor as i
said yesterday as i'll reiterate today
everyone should be able to exercise
their fundamental right whether a
protester or member of the press
peacefully and safely we cannot allow
the cycle of systemic racism and
injustice to continue
we also cannot continue going down this
path of damage and destruction
notice the disembodied language he uses
with regard to damage and destruction
nobody's actually doing anything bad
it's just that things are being seen
that put individuals families and
businesses in danger right it's
absolutely passive language
absolutely passive language right we're
going down a path of damage and
destruction
we we are assessing the damage to state
property and we'll be increasing the
presence of wisconsin national guard to
ensure individuals can exercise the
right safely protect state buildings and
critical infrastructure
and support first responders and
firefighters tonight and in the days
ahead if you're going to protest please
do so peacefully and safely
please do not allow the actions of a
feud to distract us from the work we
must do together to ensure to demand
justice equity and accountability okay
so that didn't work according to the new
york times
here's what happened during the
shootings quote many protesters left the
area
others lingered and walked to a gas
station several blocks away there a
group of men with guns stood outside
promising to protect the property and
verbally sparring with the arriving
protesters
as the night stretched on the gas
station because it became a tense
gathering spot
with bystanders watching from parked
cars and people milling around in the
street arguing and occasionally shoving
each other
police officers had crept closer to the
gas stations in armor in armored trucks
urging the people who are still there to
go home after midnight
shots were fired outside the gas station
three people were struck according to
sheriff david beth in an interview
the kenosha police department said in a
statement there were two fatalities one
person had been taken to the hospital
with injuries that were not
life-threatening sheriff beth said the
investigation was focused on a group of
men with guns outside the gas station
and then investigators were scouring
video
taken just before the shooting in one
video the men are shouting at each other
and clutching their guns and
occasionally pulling each other away to
defuse the conflict
he said i've had people saying why don't
you deputize the citizens this is why
you don't deputize citizens with guns to
protect kenosha
okay so now citizens are being put in
the situation of you can't defend your
own business because
if you defend your own business and you
get into an altercation and you shoot
somebody then obviously that's a bad
thing and also the cops can't defend
your business so presumably they should
just allow all of this to
to happen there's some video that has
emerged
of what appears to be a young white man
who's being chased down
by a group of protesters slash riders
and looters
and he falls to the ground and when they
approach him he shoots them and this is
being used as proof positive
of white racism of course now we don't
know if all the people who were shot
were white we don't know
we know at least one person was shot in
the head was white and that person
apparently
according to reporting from the daily
caller was carrying a
gun himself i guess uh was that the was
that the report it's all
unclear is a lot of this is still up in
the air so i'm just going to bring you
what i know at this point there's one
guy there's a city of daily caller
reporter helping the guy out shot in the
head as he was approaching a car
dealership presumably to do damage
to the car dealership that was one
incident that then there was another
incident
in which several people were shot when
it appears that a white young man
apparently about 17 years old was
carrying a gun and was being chased down
fell down on the street and then when he
was approached by people who looked like
they were going to attack him
he turned around and he shot them okay
so all of this will be investigated but
here is the problem
okay chaos breaks out when you allow it
to break out you know why this stuff
doesn't happen on a normal basis in the
united states
because we have police officers on the
streets who are allowed to do their jobs
and we don't imply that every time they
do do their jobs they're a bunch of
brutal racists
it turns out that when you imply that
every situation without further evidence
is evidence of police brutality and
systemic racism
and then the cops are removed from
situations people will defend their
property people will get violent people
will do stupid things on all sides
rioters and looters and predators will
attempt to prey on victims
people who don't want to be victimized
will go out there and they will
sometimes do things that are ill-advised
protecting themselves or their property
or even not protecting themselves of
their property
chaos rains when the mob rules chaos
rains when mob rules and that is what we
are watching right now
the mob is ruling in kenosha
this is what happens when you completely
deride
the police on the basis of no evidence
by the way okay because i'm going to
bring you some more evidence in the
jacob lake case
it turns out that the entire original
story at least large parts of it will
lie
we were told by benjamin crump that
jacob blake was going to a house to
break up a domestic disturbance good
samaritan jacob blake
who had a warrant out for three separate
crimes including
one involving domestic abuse and another
involving sexual assault
third degree sexual assault okay but but
he was he was the good guy there
according to benjamin crump and then for
no reason the cops just gunned him down
then there was video that emerged
yesterday of jacob blake resisting
arrest
fighting off the police officers we
still don't know it was in his hand we
still don't know is in his car when he
leaned into the car
and then being shots that changed the
story somewhat now we have the radio
scanner audio
of the call regarding the police and you
know what they show
it shows the police knew full well there
was an open warrant out for the guy and
he was apparently according to the
police scanner
the instigator of the incident that
caused all of this to happen in the
first place he went to somebody's house
where he wasn't supposed to be and he
stole the woman's keys
he stole the woman's keys and that's why
the cops got called in and they were
called in presumably
by somebody who is a person of color
that's why the cops were there in the
first place
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first there are a thousand
reasons why protecting your home matters
to you these days you may have noticed
it seems like you could use some more
stuff to protect your house
to know what's going on on your property
and directly outside your property for
me
it's peace of mind and public figure i
want to know who exactly is pulling up
outside my house but for you it might be
something as simple as you don't want
somebody stealing
boxes from your mailbox or you don't
want somebody sneezing on a package
directly before they put it in your
mailbox
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside and out best
of all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are directly
from your phone
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know it's
peace of mind anytime
knowing that your home is protected you
can see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere literally anywhere
thousands of miles away with video
doorbells and keep an eye on every
corner of your house with easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams that's
good for me because i have kids who are
constantly
little suicide machines and i like to
keep an eye on them by using the cameras
get a special offer on the ring video
welcome kit at ring.com
ben it comes with rings video doorbell 3
and chime pro it is the perfect way to
start your ring
of the security today it's free two-day
shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com go check them out right
now
ring.com ben okay so
here are some of the police audio of the
of the
the blake call the jacob blake call it
turns out
that the police were called to the
situation knowing there was a man there
with an open warrant who was apparently
harassing a woman and stealing her keys
so no he was not there apparently by the
police audio
to break up a fight he was not a good
samaritan he resisted arrest
we don't know it was in his hand you
don't walk away from the cops while
they're pointing guns at your back
and then reach into your car unless you
want to get shot that is an idiotic move
it doesn't mean that this is a fully
justified shooting it means it's going
to be very difficult to prosecute police
officers when literally you buck the
police officers off your back
walk away from them while you're under
there's an open warrant for his arrest
right they're arresting him he bucks the
police officers off his back and then he
walks around the side of his car and
reaches
into the car okay there's an open
warrant out for domestic abuse and he's
got three kids in the back of the car
what are they supposed to do let him go
explain this to me seriously explain
this to me but apparently this is worthy
of burning down the entire city of
kenosha and every major politician in
america
claiming that this is an incident of
police brutality and police racism here
is some of the radio scanner audio of
the blake
call that caused the police to show up
in the first place
2805403 280540 street
complaint says jacob blake isn't
supposed to be there and he took the
complainants keys and refused is
refusing to get them back
headquarters 6 18 707 just for 43. we
have a
alert at this address for 99 for that
subject
don't know something shock
okay within 40 seconds the rescuers were
on their way that's why jacob blake is
still
alive okay so they knew that he was a
felon
that was an open warrant for him he
would the 911 was called because he had
stolen keys from a woman
okay this was not the case of innocent
black man being pulled over by the
police for no reason
complying with all police orders and
then being shot for his trouble that is
not what this case was
not from the beginning not now but it
doesn't matter
because our media and our politicians
have an interest in polarizing the
debate and suggesting that america
systemically races and thus
every flashpoint shooting that is caught
on tape is evidence of police racism
this has driven piece of human debris
sean king an absolutely awful human
being to tweet out and bernie sanders
delegate by the way to the kenosha
police department if you do not name the
officer who brutally shot jacob blake on
sunday
we will simply begin naming officers
from your department who may or may not
be him
effort your protection of his identity
is unethical what's his name
well maybe they're not naming him
because pieces of crap like sean king
are then going to activate a bunch of
people to harass the police officer in
the absence of evidence and the absence
of an investigation
maybe because this mob justice has no
justice at all it's just garbage people
doing garbage things maybe it's
that sean king and by the way the fact
that sean king is doing this is
unbelievable considering
that there is a person who actually
committed suicide not all that long ago
because sean king misidentified him as a
particular
criminal according to abc13.com this is
just last year
robert paul cantrell 49 was found by
staff at the montgomery county jail
early
on tuesday july 29th he was found dead
in his
he was found dead in his cell he was
hanged in an apparent suicide staff
tried to revive him and perform cpr
he was in jail on a charge of robbery
evading he was wrongly accused in the
shooting death
of a seven-year-old earlier this year
why
because sean king put up a twitter post
of his picture
it was the wrong guy so definitely i
want sean king to be in charge of mob
justice in the united states
great move everybody really really
strong stuff here
mob justice is no justice social justice
by the way is also no justice individual
justice is the only kind of justice that
matters
but have you noticed that people are
studiously avoiding individual justice
we don't look at the individual
circumstances of cases
all we do is we look at the color of the
people involved and then make a snap
decision
on what exactly happened i don't know
what happened in these shootings last
night
you don't either yet we'll find out i
don't have all the details on jacob
blake but i'm happy to wait until all
the details come out you know what
nobody else is happy to do wait until
all the details come out cause they have
a pre-existing narrative
by which mob justice and social justice
matter more than individual justice the
minute
you add any modifier to justice other
than the word individual you are now
part of the bad guy crew
you are the problem not the solution
individual justice is the solution
not collective justice not social
justice and certainly not the mob
justice that we are seeing
right now jamal bowman who is a
a person who's about to enter congress
he just took over elliot angleseed in a
primary
he's one of the new members of the squad
here's what he tweeted out we need joe
biden and kamal harris to condemn the
armed militias that killed two people in
kenosha yesterday
while working in tandem with local
police these militias are domestic
terrorists
looking to incite a race war protecting
private property is cover
for their agenda so in other words if
you showed up and you protected your own
private property according to jamal
bowman kamala harris and joe biden
should condemn you but if you're there
to burn down somebody's store well then
you remember the good guy crew
solid solid stuff we're gonna get to
more of this
honestly the republican national
convention should just show this crap on
a loop
on a loop just forget the convention in
two hours tonight you'll just be
dedicated
to showing this stuff on a loop because
this is the choice
right now cave to this mob or don't cave
to the mob as we'll see the mob is
coming to your suburb soon
we'll get to that in just a moment first
you know how strongly i believe in
individual liberty and personal
responsibility our founding fathers knew
these were cornerstones of a great
civilization which is why they created
the second amendment so you can protect
yourself that said owning a rifle is an
awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different which is
why i'm so impressed with the bravo
company manufacturing
company the people at bravo company mfg
support the right of responsible private
individuals to have the access and
ability to employ the same tools as
civilian law enforcement as a means of
defending ourselves our loved ones our
communities our freedoms should a
threatening situation ever arise
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a life or
death situation by a responsible citizen
law enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas so quality is about most value
every component of a bcm rifle is hand
assembled and tested
by americans as an american you have the
luxury of living in a free society where
you can improve your life through
education
religious exploration and the open
exchange of ideas all of those rights
in the end are guaranteed by your
ability to protect yourself and your
rights to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to bravo
company mfg.com you can discover more
about their fantastic products
special offers upcoming news that is
bravo company mfg.com if you need more
convincing
find out even more about bcm and the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com
bravo company usa it's not enough that
you should own a gun you should know how
to use it
you should also have a gun that works
properly and you should be a responsible
law-abiding gun-running citizen to
protect yourself and protect your family
it's an important thing go check them
out bravocompanymfg.com
okay so again there are real
consequences to this sort of
insanity consequences on a life
on a life basis i mean people were shot
last night in kenosha
not by the cops and they were shot last
night there are consequences to business
there's a place called gravity gaming
lounge that posted this on facebook last
night quote for those that heard we got
looted
everything in the store was taken the
place was destroyed for a business that
was struggling to get back to normal and
pushing through these hard times
we will not be able to come back from
this the damage to our building the cost
to replace the exterior damage and to
top it off to replace everything
stolen is going to be catastrophic as we
look to see the total cost at this point
we'll be closing down
completely and this is what happens in
cities when you allow
all of this crap to happen when all of
this crap is allowed to run
roughshod where the mob rules again
chaos
follows and that is what you're seeing
and you're seeing it spread into the
suburbs this is not relegated to high
crime areas anymore
you're starting to see people being
harassed in public places remember that
time
when it was just about if you're a trump
official we're gonna yell at you at a
restaurant well no longer
now we're just going to yell at you no
matter where you are
there was a a an unbelievable tape
yesterday
of a crew of people harassing a woman
at a washington dc outdoor restaurant
she's just sitting there by the way
she says that she's repeatedly marched
with black lives matters she just was
not going to be bullied into doing
anything by a mob so good for her
good for her well done everybody here in
the crowd apparently one of the people
who was doing this crap was a writer for
dead spin
his name was modiano his name was
modiano
and this modiano character chuck modiano
he um he decided that he couldn't
understand
why she was the only diner in the area
who wouldn't comply with the man what
was in you you couldn't do this and
victor who's an urban planner the name
the woman's name
is um is victor her name her name is
lauren b victor
she said i felt i was under attack she
said that there was something wrong
about being coerced to show support she
said i wasn't actually frightened i
didn't think they'd do anything to me
i'm very much with then
then i've been marching with them for
weeks and weeks and weeks but here's
captain dead spin over here bullying a
woman and getting in her face and
screaming at her face in the middle of a
covey pandemic so solid stuff here
from your blm crew
[Applause]
so we get malice shaming mobs this is
really exciting stuff
so now now that the the law is on the
side of the bomb it's on the side of the
bullies
now some of the great heroes in american
history are people who withstood the mob
to stand up for their rights and people
like john lewis literally withstood a
racist mob
to sit and just take a milkshake at a
lunch counter right
that is great american heroism now the
same people claiming john lewis's mantle
are trying to shout people into
submission and bully them into putting
up a fist
okay if you're trying to claim john
lewis's mantle you're doing that you're
a piece of crap
meanwhile more people were being
threatened at dining yesterday here was
uh here's another tape from washington
dc where people were being mobbed and
shouted at for the great crime of not
raising a fist in solidarity
with this marxist blm organization
here's
here here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
how delightful apparently the people
being bullied here also work with people
who have mental instability issues i'm
not kidding mental instability issues
disproportionately minority those are
the people being screamed out here
that is what the social media has found
so again incredibly incredibly well done
and of course
things have not let up in portland last
night in portland things continued to be
riotous
there were more riots in portland last
night the governor of
of oregon was like you know it'd be
great if you stop this violence oh
has that occurred to you we're now three
months in and in seattle
according to my friend jason rant over
at ktth
seattle rioters used a substance
suspected to be quick dry concrete
to seal shut the door to the east
precinct the seattle police department
has confirmed
and then a rioter attempted to set fire
to the building after concreting people
in the building
now the bureau of alcohol tobacco
firearms and explosives
is working with the seattle pd on this
investigation rioters assaulted
seattle's east precinct
on monday night this marked another
night of violent criminal activism
against police officers unconnected to
anger over a recent police shooting
in wisconsin according to ktth some in
the crowd vandalized the building and
tormented police
others brought quick dry cement to seal
police officers inside the building
so just wonderful wonderful behavior all
the way around
good thing that they slashed the salary
of the police chief in seattle carmen
best forcing her to quit
the black female police chief of seattle
who has now quit so all of this
it turns out is not resounding to the
benefit of democrats which led
don lemon to say the quiet part out loud
which is guys the writing and the
looting were all fine and you know the
beating of people in the streets and the
bullying oh that was fine but now people
are starting to become aware so probably
joe biden should say something about it
here is don lemon saying oh you know it
was fine until it started to affect the
democrats poll numbers i think this is a
blind spot
for democrats i think democrats are
ignoring this problem are hoping that it
will go away
and it's not going to go away and so
unless someone comes up with a solution
over the next
73 days or 70 so however many days
68 days 68 days so it's not gonna that
the problem is not going to be
fixed by then but what they can do
and i think maybe joe biden may be
afraid to do it
i'm not sure maybe he won't maybe he is
he's got to address it
he shouldn't he should address it not
because it's bad you see he should
address it because it's going to affect
his poll numbers
you see the narrative must always be
maintained when joe biden addresses it
what he should discuss is systemic
american racism of course
that's the real problem he should
discuss systemic american racism and why
it's leading to rioting and looting
so uh there are no words for the the
media are complicit in this kind of crap
by the way
i'm gonna get to that in a second
because the media are absolutely
complicit they are pushing it
they continue to push false narratives
about police action in the absence of
evidence they've been doing it for
literally years
every major incident of the last five
years probably has been misconstrued by
the media originally without waiting for
any of the available facts
actively misconstrued by the media every
single one i'm i'm struggling to think
of one that has not been misconstrued
maybe
the only one i can think of is philando
castile that is the only one that i can
think of that has not been actively
misconstrued
or miscovered by the media the freddie
gray situation in baltimore was was
considered an act of police racism
the autopsy found that the police did
not in fact beat freddie gray to death
or purposefully kill freddie gray
the eric garner incident was considered
an act of police racism despite the fact
that the sergeant on duty and who was
watching over all of it was black and
the fact that eric garner
died of the fact of his pre-existing
conditions he did not actually die of
being
choked out in that particular situation
doesn't mean he should have died but the
original details are not the original
story the ray shard brooks shooting
is a situation where a man took a taser
tased two cops wrestled them to the
ground
and then was shot for his trouble the
michael brown shooting was not a
situation of a black man
surrendering to police hands up don't
shoot it was a lie it was a lie from the
beginning the
the media went with it anyway it is
difficult to think of a situation where
the media did not
miscover the situation dramatically and
in the wrong direction from the very
outset declaring that it was a symptom
of deeper underlying american racism
and we're watching that right now in a
variety of cases in a variety of cases
i'll get some more details on that
in just one second the deep
irresponsibility of our media that have
one job and that is to actively report
the facts
not to report a narrative not to report
the 16 19 projects lies about america
to report the fact and their abject
irresponsibility and refusal to do so
is leading to what we are seeing in the
streets right now
and get some more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about your hair okay if
you're a dude good shot that you're
gonna lose
your hair can we get into our 20s and
30s and start noticing the first signs
of hair loss
well it's panic time and that is why you
need to go get the medication you need
to make sure that you don't go bald two
out of three dudes are going to
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they are 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
you used to have to go to a doctor's
office for a hair loss prescription now
thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication delivered directly
to your home they make it easy they
deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there you may have tried them before
but never
for this price prevention is key keeps
treatments typically take between four
and six months to see results so it is
important to act fast the sooner you
start using keeps the more hair you will
save
there's a reason that keeps treatment
start at just 10 bucks a month plus for
a limited time you can get your first
month for free that's a fantastic deal
for getting to keep your hair if you're
ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com bender receive
your first month of treatment for free
i've used it myself
because male pattern baldness does run
in my family that is k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash band keeps dot com
slash men go check them out right now
okay we're gonna get to
the dramatic media miscoverage of nearly
every major
police-involved incident of the last
several years
but first the rnc is off to a great
start blowing the dnc out of the water
in nearly every way
in fact online c-span viewership six
times the opening night of the dnc which
is a huge number
daily wire is matching this enthusiasm
with an even better lineup of all access
live
to watch the rnc with you over at
dailywire.com starting tonight
at 8 15 p.m eastern 5 15 p.m pacific our
own matt walsh will be once again
sacrificing himself for you
he'll be live streaming the entire night
of rnc speakers and watching with you
taking your comments and questions
letting you know what he thinks in real
time and we'll be hosting more live
watch parties every day for the rest of
the week so you do not miss out
all access members gets to join these
all access live sessions where one of us
jumps on every night to chat with you
both in live stream and in the comments
i'll access membership also features not
one but two leftist years tumblers with
your membership as well as early and
sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products so head on
over to dailywire.com shapiro right now
to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that's dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so our garbage media continuing to try
to have false
story after false story not to look at
details to ignore the realities of
situations
on the ground so the one obviously that
is most celebrated is george floyd in
which derek shaven supposedly murdered
george fly like murdered him
they're going to charge him with
second-degree murder which is a
completely ungettable charge
okay keith ellison is not going to be
able to to get a conviction on that
charge prediction right now not based on
the available facts
now derek chavin may have engaged in
assault he may have engaged in police
brutality
there is no evidence that he murdered
george floyd at this point
okay the autopsies there have been a
couple of separate autopsies
george floyd did not die of asphyxiation
from derek chalvin in fact
there is now a hennepin county
attorney's office memorandum that has
been released
the met this was a medical examination
that was done by dr andrew baker
okay he did the final toxicology results
on george floyd's blood samples
and he analyzed a bunch of factors and
here's what he found
dr baker said that he walked down the
list of substances
for which the labs tested he said that
there are low levels of methamphetamine
but when it came to fentanyl he said the
fentanyl levels were quote pretty high
it was an 11 apparently this level of
fentanyl can cause pulmonary
edema mr floyd's lungs were two to three
times their normal weight at autopsy
that is a fatal level of fentanyl under
normal circumstances
according to the doctor if floyd had
been found dead in his home or anywhere
else and there were no other
contributing factors he would conclude
it was an overdose death
so in other words you actually have to
show causation if you're going to show
murder
okay it's very difficult to show
causation in this particular case this
is true from the original county autopsy
it's going to remain true you're not
going to hear any of that the media are
just going to ignore it
they're going to ignore it because they
have to claim that derek chalvin is not
only
a murderer but also he's a racist so
even if he had killed george floyd
there's still no evidence he's a racist
we're waiting on that doesn't matter the
media ran with the story anyway
it's systemic police racism systemic
police brutality and cruelty
and they're going to ignore the fact
that george for the tape shows that
george floyd was saying he couldn't
breathe
before he was on the ground that he was
resisting arrest they're going to avoid
the fact
that minneapolis police procedure allows
you to put somebody in a submission hold
in that way if you believe that they are
suffering from a particular type of
condition
i've read you the manual before okay
it's going to be very difficult to
receive a conviction on that basis
so the media have yet to actually
fulfill their pledge on what happened to
george floyd doesn't matter the
narrative has been set
derrick chavin is a racist murderer in
the brianna taylor death oprah winfrey
is taking out full
on billboards about brianna taylor's
death now the original claim
is that brianna taylor was the
girlfriend of a guy who was a drug
dealer and that she had nothing to do
with drug dealing right she was not
involved in any way
that they basically falsified an arrest
warrant to go to briana taylor's
apartment and search her apartment but
they had no real basis for doing so
and so therefore the warrant was flawed
okay then there's a dispute as to what
happened they had a no knock warrant to
go into briana taylor's apartment
they knocked anyway right by all
accounts they knocked anyway according
to brianna taylor's boyfriend who is
still alive the the
alleged drug dealer he they they did not
announce themselves
and so when they started to force in the
door he took a shot at them at which
point they shot into the apartment and
they shot him and killed brianna taylor
now number one if they have no knock
warrant they don't actually have to
announce themselves number two the
police say they did announce themselves
so even that is in dispute
but the entire case that the cops are
going to be criminally liable
for any charges in the brianna taylor
shooting
are likely to rest on the insufficiency
of the warrant itself
the suggestion that the warrant was
falsified well earlier this month
abc news reported that experts say there
are serious obstacles to charging police
in the brianna taylor case
attorney general daniel cameron the
first african-american elected to the
job in kentucky's book at the rnc last
night
has declined to put a timetable on his
decision since taking over the case
in may according to christopher slobogan
director of the criminal justice program
at vanderbilt university he said it's a
tough issue
he has to figure out whether there's
probable cause to believe there was an
unreasonable use of force difficult to
make that case when somebody is
literally shooting at you from inside an
apartment
taylor's boyfriend kenny walker was with
her at the apartment and fired a shot at
lewisville
louisville police sergeant jonathan
mattingly after the door was broken down
mattingly was struck in the leg and
returned fire along with other officers
who were outside the apartment
taylor was unarmed she was shot several
times in her hallway and died on the
scene
the officers were not wearing body
cameras there's no video of the raid the
warrant they were carrying has come
under scrutiny and the police lieutenant
who sought at joshua james
has been placed on administrative leave
during the investigation attorneys for
taylor's family
said it was based on erroneous
information that a drug dealer was
sending packages to taylor's apartment
so according to the experts sam
markusson university of louisville law
professor he says
the warrant combined with the fact that
they were fired upon would make for a
powerful defense argument that they
acted
in valid self-defense while conducting a
lawful police operation
basically they have to prove several
things to prove that these officers
should go to jail
one they would have to show that the
warrant were obtained fraudulently two
they would have had to show the officers
were aware that the warrant was obtained
fraudulently police department protocol
allows the use of lethal force when
officers feel threatened even if they
had a valid no knock warrant and
properly announced themselves
blazing away could theoretically be an
excessive use of force but when somebody
is firing at you that sort
of changes the math a little bit so in
other words it's going to be nearly
impossible to reach conviction in the
brianna taylor case
and if somebody's firing at you from
inside an apartment where you have a
warrant a justly based warrant
how do you make the case that the police
officers ought to go to jail
that that is just called a tragedy is
not necessarily called a crime
okay well now it turns out there are new
details now there are new tales
new details that are being largely
ignored by the national media they're
being covered locally
according to the courier journal the
conte the louisville
courier journal apparently there's a new
report it's a 39-page report
and it details significant ties beyond
between brianna taylor
and the alleged drug dealer so this is
only relevant it's not relevant to her
being shot it is relevant to whether
they properly obtained the warrant if it
turns out there was significant evidence
that brianna taylor was part
of a drug distribution network then it
would make sense that they had a no
knock warrant for her apartment
so again you have to fulfill three steps
to convict the brianna taylor officers
one
you have to claim that the arrest
warrant was fraudulent two the officers
knew it was fraudulent
three they then went in guns blazing to
shoot somebody
all three of these are going to be found
false doesn't matter the narrative has
already been set
according to the courier journal an
internal report written by louisville
metro police after officers fatally shot
brianna taylor on march 13th
sheds more light on the reasons why they
chose to forcibly enter her south end
apartment
the night she was killed the 39-page
report and corroborating evidence show
taylor had more extensive ties than
previously made public with an accused
drug trafficker who's at the center of a
larger narcotics operation in louisville
apparently according to the report
corroborated by jail phone recordings
and other documents obtained by the
courier journal detail multiple links
between taylor and jamarcus glover of
louisville a main target in a drug probe
that prompted police to request the
search
warrant for taylor's apartment
plainclothes officers that night
battered in her door searching for drugs
and illicit cash
none were found glover was arrested the
same night as taylor's shooting he was
picked up at an alleged drug house 10
miles to the north in louisville's west
end
okay so it is unclear whether
prosecution should take place here of
the officers it is certainly
not clear that this arrest warrant and
the and the warrant that was out for
opening up the apartment the no knock
warrant was improperly based
of course the mayor condemned the
release of the report because only one
side of the information can get out
when you're condemning information for
being dropped that's generally an
indicator that you don't like the
information that is being dropped
apparently the courier journal reported
that a sworn affidavit affidavit from
the louisville metro police department
detective joshua james
said glover who was the boyfriend was
seen walking into taylor's apartment one
january afternoon
and left with with a suspected usps
package in his right hand
and the then drove to a known drug house
on muhammad ali boulevard
jane said he verified through us postal
inspector glover had been receiving
packages
at taylor's address as the police report
reviewed by the career journal goes
beyond the information in the affidavit
it details evidence into police
surveillance of taylor and glover as
well as recorded phone conversations
from the jail involving the two of them
okay so again these are new details that
you probably will not see a lot
in the national media because of the
narrative has been set that the police
officers did something deeply wrong and
not only wrong racist
the they're the only way that you can
explain the consistent pattern of the
media refusing to cover in
in the national press the details of
these cases before allowing the jump to
the conclusion that the police are
systemically racist
is because they have an agenda america's
systemically racist remove the cops
and give democrats power and all this
will go away amazing okay so
as i say none of this makes for a better
america none of it
if you can name something that has
gotten better in america over the last
several months
since the george floyd killing then i'm
willing to hear it but i have yet to
hear a single thing
one like a thing that has gotten better
we've been told that america is getting
better day by day
because of the blm movement i'm waiting
to see evidence that this is the case
i've not seen any evidence that this is
the case in fact and in fact most
americans
have gone back to their prior opinions
of what they thought the state of the
state of the state of play was
before blm really gained national
prominence again after the george floyd
death
and so all of this was the backdrop for
the rnc
last night on the rnc last night was
sort of a kind and friendly
rnc last night in fact the rnc actually
opened with a prayer for jacob blake
as well as the police here was the
beginning of the rnc night two
i'm going to invite you to join your
faith with mine
and let's pray in agreement lord we come
before you
to ask for your spirit of peace to come
over hurting communities in wisconsin
tonight
we pray for healing and comfort to jacob
blake and his family
we pray for your protection over those
who put their lives
in harm's way to bring safety and
security to our streets
so that's how the rnc open right kinder
gentler rnc now it seems to me that with
the democrats
in absolute hiding over all of this joe
biden refuses to condemn it joe biden
refusing them the writing and the
looting and the violence all he does is
mouth
platitudes about systemic racism with no
possible solutions in sight
except for elect the octogenarian
democrat who's done
nothing over the course of his career to
alleviate racial tensions and actually
significant things to exacerbate racial
tensions and who was called a racist by
his own vp candidate five minutes ago
right that's the agenda here
and where is he where is he the cities
are burning where is he
the mob is ruling where is he so
the the rnc is happening against that
basis
and the rnc pursued several different
themes last night
it was a more typical rnc night uh they
pursued some issues on foreign policy
they pursued some issues on the media a
lot of attention to the media last night
well deserved because the media are just
in arm of the democratic party at this
point pushing a narrative rather than a
factual
fact pattern nick sandman was featured
here and the media went nuts
right so nixon they should he he
literally is now an owner of cnn
so nick sandman of course is the is the
teenager who is targeted by the media as
a racist for the great crime of standing
there wearing a maga hat
as a native american activist got in his
face and banged a drum in his face
along with members of the black hebrew
israelites
well nick sandman spoke at the rnc last
night about the full war machine of the
media
absolutely true and necessary what i
thought was a strange
encounter quickly developed into a major
news story
complete with video footage my life
changed forever in that one moment
the full war machine of the mainstream
media revved up into attack mode
they did so without researching the full
video of the incident
without ever investigating mr phillips
motives
or without ever asking me for my side of
the story
and do you know why because the truth
was not important correct the truth is
not important to the media i mean nick
sandman going after the media last night
the media lost it
media lost it is he an analyst named joe
lockhart he actually tweeted out
that this kid he said i'm watching
tonight because it's important but i
don't have to watch this snot-nosed
entitled kid from kentucky
yeah i feel like the the lack of
self-awareness in the media
is half the problem here it is at least
half the problem
so the rnc again has been a well-run
operation
it's technically nice to look at i mean
like it's it's well produced
and there were several themes last night
the biggest theme of the rnc overall
continues to be
that trump is really now what this
election is about so the entire dnc was
based around the idea that trump is the
election
but as it turns out many americans
looking at what's happening on their tvs
now
and looking at it on the internet
because you can only get the news from
the internet now from central right
sources
they're beginning to realize that this
election is not about trump it's in fact
about
movements in the country one movement
that suggests that the mob ought to rule
that the protesters ought to be treated
as wonderful and good even if they
evolve into rioters and looters over the
course of the night they're the best
among us as barack obama suggested
and another group of people who say you
know what you're allowed to protest
you're not allowed to right you are not
allowed to loot we still have a republic
here and the mob does not rule here
the the mob should not be given one inch
it should not be given one inch
and the idea of the democratic party
that the mob should rule in the absence
of democratic rule and that if democrats
do rule then the mob should basically go
away because the mob's agenda has been
channeled into legislation
that is an ugly ugly election item
you're going to watch the polls and
arrow you're already starting to see the
polls and arrow
this is not going to be a blowout
election not if the democrats continue
to give way to the mob americans do not
like the mob
americans like their republic and the
only way they're going to keep it is if
they back it
don't give one shred or iota of power to
people who promulgate false narratives
on the basis of lack of fact
and then give credence to mobs of
rioters and looters and violent thugs
in order to do so okay don't do it
don't give those people one iota of
power they don't deserve it
okay so again the rnc happens last night
it was a bit of a different
rnc night uh sort of a wide variety of
people who are speaking there are some
really
i thought good moments and they pointed
out the radicalism of the democratic
agenda so one of the people who spoke
with graham lynch
who was the daughter of the
granddaughter of billy graham and she
points out that one of the agenda items
for so many of the democrats is to
silence faith which
obviously is true joe biden has
suggested that little sisters of the
poor nuns should be paying for
contraceptive coverage
joe biden has reversed himself on the
hyde amendment he says that you should
pay for abortions
kamala harris has suggested that
religion essentially ought to be
relegated to the private sphere that if
you run a business you should not be
allowed to live out your religion in
everyday life
here was graham lynch talking
about how faith was not supposed to be
silenced in the united states it's why
we have a first amendment
we know the first line of the first
amendment protects our freedom of
religion
but what we often forget the actual
words are free
exercise of religion that means living
out our faith in our daily lives
in our schools and our jobs and yes
even in the public square our founders
did not envision a quiet
hidden faith they fought to ensure that
the voices of faith
were always welcomed not silenced
not bullied she of course was ripped up
and down because
how dare she say things about faith no
one's trying to silence your faith
except for the democratic party agenda
which actually wants to make faith
subservient to whatever is the
government's social position
of the day abby johnson also spoke she
of course
is an advocate on behalf of life she
used to be a a branch manager
at an abortion clinic for planned
parenthood she used to be one of the
chief pro-choice advocates in the
country and now she is extremely
pro-life the media came for her last
night because the media decided that she
is very bad
msnbc cut away from this by the way they
went to commercial break while abby
johnson was speaking specifically
because you are not allowed
in the mainstream media to graphically
discuss what abortion constitutes this
is the one thing you're not allowed to
do
you're allowed to pretend that abortion
is just reproductive health care one of
the things you're not supposed to do
is openly discuss what abortion is which
is one of the reasons why every time i
speak about abortion publicly i do
exactly what abby johnson does here when
i'm at the march for life i graphically
discuss what an abortion is
and what the feelings of the baby are
and how well-developed children are in
the womb
i did it on fox news in fact when i was
on fox news and i did an election
special
in 2018. i did a full segment on
abortion and i actually wanted to show
pictures
of unborn babies in the womb and some
graphic images and even fox news which
is a which is a right wing network
wouldn't let me do it we had to show
animations instead here was abby johnson
last night graphically discussing
abortion at the rnc which is by the way
what you should discuss
you know we've been told that to raise
awareness you should discuss the graphic
nature of real events on the ground
unless it's an abortion then you just
you know brush it away with some
euphemisms
the physician asked me to assist with an
ultrasound
guided abortion nothing prepared me
for what i saw on the screen an
unborn baby fighting back desperate
to move away from the suction and
i'll never forget what the doctor said
next
beam me up scotty the last thing
i saw was a spine twirling around
in the mother's womb before succumbing
to the force
of the suction okay now i know there are
a bunch of democrats who are like
how could she be so graphic because
would you like to know what goes on
would you like to shield your eyes from
from what
exactly goes on so honestly i think it's
an important message and i think it's
it's a good message and i'm glad that
abby johnson spoke it okay other
elements of the rnc last night mike
pompeo was ripped up and down for the
great sin he violated the hatch act we
were told the hatch act
because the hatch act is generally
unenforceable it's very rarely enforced
the hatch act basically says you're not
allowed to use public resources to push
politics
this happens all the time okay seriously
like if you think public officials don't
push politics on public grounds uh
you're out of your mind
and the obama administration violated
the hatch act seven ways from sunday by
this broad iteration of it
by the way six separate cabinet
secretaries spoke on behalf of barack
obama
in 2012 but when mike pompeo speaks from
jerusalem on behalf of donald trump
then apparently that's very bad here was
mike pompeo the secretary of sp
state speaking on behalf of the trump
foreign policy which by the way
again his middle eastern policy has
achieved the first serious peace deal in
the region
since 1994 and donald trump has been
given no credit
in the media by it like literally no
credit here is mike pompeo talking about
it
this president has led bold initiatives
in nearly every corner of the world
in china he's pulled back the curtain on
the predatory aggression
of the chinese communist party in north
korea the president lowered the
temperature
and against all odds got the north
korean leadership to the table
the president too moved the u.s embassy
to this very city of god jerusalem
the rightful capital of the jewish
homeland
and just two weeks ago the president
brokered a historic peace deal
between israel and the united arab
emirates
okay so honestly that is good i mean the
fact is that they had john kerry speak
about trump's foreign policy and rip
into it they had barack obama do some of
the same sort of stuff
they had a wide variety of political
figures from the democratic party rip
into trump's foreign policy
i'm glad that pompeo defended the
foreign policy i think that they're very
stupid president i mean i said by the
way i thought it was a stupid precedent
that presidents couldn't rip their their
heirs like i think george w bush should
have had some things to say about barack
obama
i don't care they're politicians this
this idiotic notion that politicians
shouldn't speak politically
once they're off the stage or that if
you're the secretary of state we have to
assume that you're a non-partisan
political figure
is asinine in the extreme so not only am
i not hypocritical on it i actually said
it last week with regard to barack obama
these are precedents that just don't
matter i'm glad that mike pompeo spoke
at the rnc okay it was also family night
at the rnc
there's a lot of trump a lot of trump so
tiffany trump spoke
and she points out the differences
between right and left i thought tiffany
trump did
a pretty good job of pointing out the
differences between right and left here
are some of the things that we believe
in as americans if you believe in these
you should probably join us
we believe in equality of opportunity
we believe in freedom of thought and
expression
think what you want seek out the truth
learn from those with different opinions
and then freely
make your voice heard to the world we
believe in school choice because a child
zip code in america
should not determine their future we
believe in freedom of religion for
all faiths and we believe
in the american spirit hey she did a
good job last night tiffany so did eric
eric spoke last night he said
that one of the big conflicts here is
there's a group of people who would like
to erase american history and there's a
group of people who would like to
preserve american history
here is eric trump speaking last night
in the view of the radical democrats
america is the source of the world's
problems
as a result they believe the only path
forward is to raise history
and forget the past they want to destroy
the monuments of our forefathers
they want to disrespect our flag burn
the stars and stripes that represent
patriotism
and the american dream they want to
disrespect our national anthem by taking
a knee
while our armed forces lay down their
lives every day
to protect our freedom again these
contrasts are very useful to republicans
the dnc was largely about pasting over
a bubbling pot of anti-american
sentiment
you know no under god in the pledge of
allegiance in the early hours of the dnc
and you can kneel for the national
anthem america systemically racist with
some joe biden sort of pasteboard
patriotism where he talks about how much
he goes to church and how much he loves
the american flag and all of this kind
of stuff
and the fact is that it goes a little
bit deeper than that for a lot of
republicans by the way this is what the
polls show
the polls show that democrats are
patriotic when democrats are in office
and when republicans are in office the
patriotism dives
republicans have generally been
patriotic whether or not a democrat
is in office okay the polls do show this
gallup has been showing this for years
okay then melania spoke and even the
media were forced to acknowledge that
melania did a good job last night here
was melania trump
really taking on a couple of issues she
took on racial unrest and she took on
covet
and she actually provided a voice of
reason on this particular issue she said
i'm not going to spend tonight
attacking the other side the way the
democrats have been
as you have heard this evening i don't
want to use this precious time
attacking the other side because as we
saw last week
that kind of talk only serves to divide
the country further i'm here because we
need my husband to be our president
and commander-in-chief for four more
years
he is what is best for our country
okay and then melania got into covenant
and she acknowledged that people are
worried about covet but she points out
the federal government
has been doing its best to prevent the
transmission by the way there are
upticks in europe right now
again nobody has a great strategy on
covet it burns through communities the
best you can do is protect the
vulnerable
and encourage people to take steps to
slow the spread by keeping social
distancing and wearing masks in crowded
areas that is literally all you can do
there are no other answers here's
melania trump talking about covid
i want to acknowledge the fact that
since march
our lives have changed drastically
the invisible enemy coveted 19
swept across our beautiful country and
impacted all of us my husband's
administration
will not stop fighting until there is an
effective treatment
or vaccine available to everyone
donald will not rest until he has done
all he can to take care of everyone
impacted by this terrible pandemic and
melania trump
also took a nuanced view of american
history now this is something we've been
told republicans can't do which is
amazing because in my new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps i think it's a pretty nuanced view
of american history pointing out all of
its flaws melania did the same thing
last night we've been told republicans
refuse to acknowledge the flaws of
american history that obviously is not
the case
like all of you i have reflected on the
racial
unrest in our country
it is a harsh reality that we are not
proud
of parts of our history i encourage
people to focus on our future
while still learning from our past
we must remember that today we are
all one community comprised of many
races
religions and ethnicities and she
concluded by saying
we should all come together in a civil
manner i mean this is a very mild and
well-spoken speech it granted a sense of
normalcy to the convention in a time of
great abnormality again the joe biden
pitch has been returned to normalcy
but things were not normal under barack
obama they have not been normal under
president trump
and they are not normal right now while
democrats completely ignore the fact
that we are watching our cities burn
here is melania trump trying to provide
that sense of normalcy
we still have so much to learn from one
another
with that in mind i like to call on the
citizens of this country
to take a moment pause and look at
things from
all perspectives i urge people
to come together in a civil manner so we
can work
and live up to our standard american
ideals
i also ask people to stop the violence
and looting being done in the name of
justice
okay all of this prompted bette midler
great democratic mind bette midler to
tweet oh god
she still can't speak english so you can
say that about melania now so that's
exciting
that she can speak english and i
guarantee you she speaks at what five or
six other languages she speaks all of
them better than bette midler speaks any
of those languages
in any language bette midler is is a
fool even politico acknowledged this was
their analysis quote first lady melania
trump
restored a sense of normalcy tuesday
night closing night two with its speech
that was remarkable for its restraint
and deliberate adherence to etiquette
that's a very strong night again night
two for the rnc reaching out to people
in the middle
who may be somewhat alienated by the
fact that our cities are burning and the
media continue to root for it
and continue to say the only reason
democrats might want to address it is
because their poll numbers are starting
to drop okay
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow with much much more all the
updates on rnc night three i believe
vice president pence goes tonight
and all the updates as kenosha wisconsin
burns among other cities this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick shien the
show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen